[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour cette
nouvelle demi heure d'information locale
voici les titres de ce mercredi 16 mai
coup d'accélérateur pour l'aménagement
du quartier des quatre arbres à elle
encourt une première réunion publique a
rassemblé plus de 200 habitants lundi
soir ils se sont vu présenter le projet
dans ses grandes lignes les premiers
travaux devraient débuter d'ici deux ans
santé éducation scolarité les sujets de
préoccupation sont nombreux pour les
parents c'est pour les soutenir dans
leur démarche que la ville de la
verrière a organisé son premier forum
parentalité aujourd'hui nous reviendrons
dessus avec notre invité
clément ortega donner envie de lire aux
plus jeunes la quinzaine de la librairie
est organisée en ce moment dans toute la
région ile-de-france des temps d'échangé
de découverte entre professionnels et
lycéens une rencontre se tenait ce matin
aux pavés du canal à montigny le
bretonneux la poste et la cité des
métiers s'engage pour le retour à
l'emploi les deux structures ont signé
aujourd'hui un partenariat pour
favoriser leur collaboration
objectif faciliter le recrutement des
demandeurs d'emploi intéressés par les
métiers de la poste dans l'ouest
parisien
un atelier spécial sera d'ailleurs
organisé le 28 mai prochain précisions
recueillies par patrick jacques de
dixmude la convention elle est née du
fait que la poste fait déjà des
permanences elle fait partie des trente
partenaires que nous avons la cité des
métiers et donc elle a voulu consolider
cette présence par une convention pour
que l'on mette en place peut-être un peu
plus de journée que ce que l'on faisait
auparavant par an bon an mal an la poste
au niveau national recrute à peu près
dix mille personnes
donc là pour l'ile-de-france secteur
ouest ces quelques dizaines de personnes
qui seront recrutées pour les besoins de
la banque postale est lésé le courtois
l'attendait depuis de nombreuses années
le projet d'aménagement du secteur des
quatre arbres se précise à elancourt
lundi se tenait une première réunion
publique en mairie les 250 habitants
présents pour l'occasion ont pu
découvrir les grandes lignes du projet
camille lambert et michael et demi
d'euros des locaux commerciaux
abandonnés d'autres vieillissant la zone
d'activités des quatre arbailles long
cours va être repensé un réaménagement
du secteur lancer en 2015 par la ville
lundi 14 mai les habitants ont été
invités en mairie pour une réunion
publique afin de présenter le projet ça
fait très longtemps qu'on en entend
parler mais ça fait très longtemps que
ça n'avance pas beaucoup donc là
j'espère que ça va commencer à
à progresser on est une association on a
des jardins et on voudrait savoir
on voudrait connaître l'avenir des
jardins si vous racheter un autre
terrain pour remettre des jardins
ailleurs et pas trop loin parce qu'il ya
des gens qu un certain âge qui n'ont pas
de voiture pour se déplacer la base du
projet prévoit la relocalisation des
jardins familiaux l'enfouissement des
lignes électriques à très haute tension
et plus globalement l'élargissement du
centre ville
cette première réunion marque le début
de la phase de concertation
on n'en est pas encore à la phase projet
avec des définitions de type logique de
bâtiments d'immeubles et cetera on en
est pour l'instant aux grandes
orientations d'aménagement le but ce
soir est d'expliquer aux gens comment
ils vont pouvoir s'investir dans ce
projet y participer y contribuer à
travers plusieurs réunions publiques des
diagnostics en marchant qui va être
organisée donc dans quelques semaines
les habitants sont invités à participer
en envoyant leurs homards qui en
s'inscrivant ateliers proposés
l'enfouissement des lignes à haute
tension est prévue pour 2020 2022
dans certaines zones les travaux
pourraient commencer plus tôt une
première à la verrière à présent la
ville organisée à cet après midi son
forum de la parentalité à un rendez vous
qui s'est déroulée dans le quartier
d'orly parc des échanges entre des
spécialistes et des parents sur
plusieurs thématiques santé scolarité ou
encore vie à la maison nicolas landry s
est rendu sur place cet après-midi
reportage
c'est pas possible
devenir un enfant de 2 ans tenter de
grimper sur une chaise de se servir à
boire ou d'aller aux toilettes
une activité ludique proposée aux
visiteurs du forum de la parentalité à
la verrière objectif prévenir des
accidents domestiques responsable de 20
mille décès chaque année dont 40 %
d'enfants
alors en fait enfants la première chose
qu'il faut voir c'est là que de
casseroles dans ce sens la première
chose il va être attiré par ce qui est à
l'intérieur
donc il va appuyer voyez avec un seul
doigt j'arrive a appuyé sur la casserole
et malheureusement la première chose qui
va lui arriver c'est que le liquide
coule sur sa tête et sur les réseaux de
parties du corps donc c'est des brûlures
minimum au deuxième degré pour un enfant
une quinzaine d'exposants des acteurs de
la santé du social ou encore de
l'éducation
l'association dix fois plus fort est
spécialisée dans l'accompagnement des
enfants ayant des troubles de
l'apprentissage
souvent c'est des problèmes de consigner
bien dire les consignes une par une ces
aussi mettre en place des petits
pictogrammes pour que les enfants
puissent avoir des repères et puis c'est
aussi va faire preuve de patience de la
part des parents c'est un événement
nouveau sur la ville mais on pense que
effectivement sur une ville où beaucoup
de parents sont deux familles sont
monoparentales notamment
ça peut être intéressant d'avoir comme
ça à un endroit où on va retrouver un
peu tous les sujets de la vie de
l'enfant
une vie dans laquelle les parents ont pu
se plonger durant un après midi tout en
bénéficiant de conseils pour l'éducation
de leurs enfants et on poursuit cette
thématique avec notre invité en plateau
clément ortega bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
le directeur de cabinet du maire de la
verrière convient de voir dans le sujet
quel bilan vous tirer de cette première
première édition c'est la première fois
qu'il y avait ce forum à la veille à ce
que les habituels et partenaires à était
au rendez vous alors les partenaires
étaient au rendez-vous le reportage de
dia il y avait effectivement l'ensemble
des partenaires institutionnels
d'ailleurs je salue entre autres
l'éducation nationale qui est qui s'est
déplacé un certain nombre d'associations
je salue d'ailleurs la fcpe qui qui
étaient là donc
l'association des parents d'élèves
l'ensemble des services de la
municipalité et puis des partenaires
dont on voit un peu moins souvent mais
l'hôpital de plaisir et elle a rassemblé
en gros tout le monde sur un même lieu
sur un même lieu mais avec qui
d'ailleurs on travaille toute l'année
parce que là c'était véritablement un
forum parentalité mais l'aide à la
parentalité on le fait toute l'année
dans les centres socioculturels mais y
avait quand même besoin de créer un tel
rendez vous est ce que ça répond à une
attente ou une demande particulière sur
sur la verrière
la maire a évoqué même que c'est une
ville forcément un peu particulière où
les moyens sont parfois moins élevés
qu'ailleurs est ce que ça ça répond à un
besoin
il ya deux éléments il ya effectivement
la question sociale et nelly du tu l'as
dit fortement effectivement est entre
autres dans le quartier où nous étions à
orly parc c'est près d'un ménage sur
trois qui est monoparentale très souvent
des femmes qui veut dire dans une
situation d'emploi très souvent
précaires à temps partiel s'il ya de
l'emploi
donc on se retrouve avec une situation
sociale compliquée ça c'est une chose
effectivement qu'il faut prendre en
compte et qui est une particularité
effectivement des villes comme comme la
verrière des villes populaires mais il
ya aussi un autre élément qui là est
partagé par toute la société c'est le
lien intergénérationnel qui s'est
transformé sous vendu parce que le monde
du travail a aussi changé mais lorsque
l'on prend par exemple un jeune couple
qui vient d'avoir des parents il ya
encore des enfants quand un jeune couple
bien d'avoir des enfants il ya 50 ans
leurs propres parents leur donnait des
éléments pour pouvoir élu
les enfants des gestes des des cadres
aujourd'hui on voit bien que les jeunes
couples aujourd'hui se retrouve isolé
avec moins de liens avec les parents et
donc cela pose un certain nombre de
clics sur glace avant finalement de
combler ce manque éventuel mais c'est à
partir du moment où la société
elles changent il faut effectivement que
les collectivités territoriales que le
service public répondent à quelques
jours afin de conserver le cadre du
vivre ensemble est d'ailleurs la journée
d'ailleurs mondial du vivre ensemble
aujourd'hui donc ça tombait très bien
que le forum parentalité soit ce jour là
mais il faut effectivement que le
service public puisse développer ce lien
intergénérationnel ce lien parents
enfants et rappeler un certain nombre
d'éléments ce que je disait un de vos
journalistes cet après midi c'est on ne
naît pas par an si tu ça c'est sûr autre
chose c'est c'est pas parce que l'on à
un enfant que l'on vient par an à 100%
et donc qu'il faut un certain nombre
d'éléments pour pouvoir le devenir
complètement justement quelles ont été
les principales demandes ou requêtes qui
ont été exprimés cet après-midi les
sujets qui intéressaient le plus les
gens et il y avait le plus d'inquiétudes
et bien il y avait la question de
l'alimentation par exemple arriver un
stand qui était sur l'alimentation sur
l'hygiène bucco-dentaire il ya eu
beaucoup d'initiatives et puis il ya eu
de la part des parents
vraiment un grand plaisir à jouer avec
cet espace qui était central au forum où
l'ensemble du mobilier que l'on peut
retrouver chez chacun d'entre nous mais
qui était apte à riom à greenwood l on a
vu pour comprendre quelle était la façon
dont on les enfants peuvent percevoir le
monde des adultes qui est loin d'être
évident et les parents les enfants
beaucoup jouer avec cela et je crois que
ça a débloqué un certain nombre de
choses c'est chez des parents alors une
dernière question sur ce sur ce sujet
les parents là ceux qui ont des grands
enfants doivent un petit peu stressé le
brevet le bac approche est ce que est ce
que la ville de la verrière mais les
choses en place justement pour pouvoir
soutenir les révisions des plus jeunes
ça fait très longtemps que la verrière
on pose la question de la réussite
scolaire comme un élément essentiel pour
l'autonomie des jeunes et donc ça fait
des années très nombreuses années que
l'on à des stages pendant les vacances
al'approche des examens quels qu'ils
soient des aides avec des gens qui
peuvent aider les enfants parfois même
avec des pédagogies qui sont en dehors
de celles qui sont classiques à l'école
pour permettre de mieux comprendre pour
débloquer des choses dans la tête des
des jeunes al'approche des examens donc
oui ça fait des dizaines d'années que
l'on qu'on le fait on leur fait cette
année c'est essentiel la mère l'a redit
la réussite scolaire est un axe
prioritaire la jeunesse est un axe
prioritaire de la politique de la ville
clément ortega une dernière question sur
un tout autre sujet celui de l'article
paru dans le journal du dimanche il y a
quelques jours la ville de la verrière
et plus précisément le quartier du bois
de l'étang sont mentionnés pour être je
cite un article là un exemple frappant
de l'expansionnisme salafistes ou une
police des bonnes moeurs existerait
c'est ce que dit l'article évidemment la
maire de la ville elie doute eu s'est
fendu d'un communiqué dans la journée
pour dénoncer ce paraphe en question est
pointé des contrevérités quelle est
votre réaction à vous qui connaissez
bien
cette ville puisque vous en êtes le
directeur de cabinet cet article
correspond complètement à une atmosphère
que l'on voit depuis quelques années qui
consiste à pointer du doigt un certain
nombre de populations
là on a très clairement stigmatisé un
quartier une ville entière y avait
d'autres et d'autres villes aussi
mentionné dans le il y avait il ya vait
marseille aussi est à lire l'article on
avait l'impression que tout marseille
était en dehors de la république
je me porte complètement faux ce
quartier au bois de l'étang et tous
samedi et que pas qu'il y ait qu il y
ait des actes individuels de contrôle de
ça ça existe mais de façon individuelle
ce que l'île arctique
ce que dit l'article c'est au delà du
fait que c'est exagéré là où c'est faux
c'est que l'article dit que cela est
orchestré et que la république n'a plus
sa place
or et nous allons créer un événement on
montrera que ce quartier est ouvert que
il y à du vivre ensemble
il y a énormément de communautés
énormément de personnes d'origines
différentes de croyances différentes des
gens qui n'ont pas de croyance et tout
cela vit ensemble et la ville de la
verrière est très présente
la république est présente cet article
est un est un brûlot stigmatisant envers
une population je trouve ça extrêmement
grave pour le débat est là où je trouve
aussi scandaleux c'est que le
journaliste n'est jamais venu sur le
terrain est parti deux rapports qui ne
tiennent sur rien voilà ça c'est ce
qu'on aime merci clément ortega pour
votre réaction et pour votre vos
réponses en plateau vous êtes le
directeur du cabinet du maire de la
verrière merci à vous faire découvrir le
métier de libraire c'est l'un des
objectifs de la quinzaine de la
librairie organisé par la région ile de
france jusqu'au 25 mai une cinquantaine
de rencontres et est programmée sur
l'ensemble de la région l'une d'elles se
dérouler aujourd'hui mercredi à la
librairie du pavé du canal à montigny le
bretonneux les élèves du lycée emile de
bretagne ont pu rencontrer sur place
une auteure reportage de patrick jacques
de dixmude et de grégory canal et ils
étaient une vingtaine ce matin à
assister à la rencontre proposée aux
pavés du canal dans le cadre de la
quinzaine de la librairie ses élèves de
première
au lycée breteuil de montigny le
bretonneux ont pu découvrir deux métiers
de la chaîne du livre celui d'auteur
avec joy sorman venu parler de son
ouvrage sciences de la vie la profession
également deux libraires souvent mal
connue par les jeunes c'est important
d'ouvrir la librairie aux lycéens de
leur montrer que c'est un lieu voilà qui
est facile d'accès qui est ouvert que
c'est pas un lieu un peu sanctuary les
excès c'est quelque chose qui est
accessible et ouvert vous étudiants
aussi une action de la région ile de
france pour sensibiliser à l'univers du
livre et de la lecture
chaque jeune reçoit la fin de la
rencontre un chèque de 18 euros à
dépenser dans une librairie le rendez
vous aux pavés du canal a été apprécié
les lycéens ont pu échanger directement
avec le libraire est l'auteur du jour
c'est toujours un plaisir de parler avec
des artistes en fête
surtout quand moi je devenir chanteur
donc même si c'est une écrivain c'est
c'est ça reste une artiste on a pu
justement donner un autre avis sur ce
qu'on pense de la littérature
aujourd'hui et plein d'autres choses
c'était très présentable
il ya des vraies révélations il ya
quelque chose qui se passe l'écriture un
livre c'est profond et donc ça vient
remuer des questions vraiment intime
parfois et ça vient souvent là
la quinzaine de la librairie se déroule
jusqu'au 25 mai près d'une cinquantaine
de rencontres va se tenir dans toute
l'île de france
ils interviennent en prison ou dans
notre vie quotidienne et ont pour
objectif de défendre les droits des
usagers face aux dysfonctionnements
généraux des services publics et d'agir
aussi contre toute forme de
discrimination les délégués du défenseur
des droits des yvelines ont dévoilé hier
à versailles le bilan de leurs actions
en 2017 les onze délégués présents sur
l'ensemble du département ont notamment
porté près de 900 réclamations sur plus
de 1600 saisine attrapé guyancourt des
permanences sont ouvertes
un jour par semaine grâce à d
ni vol ils nous ont expliqué leur rôle
et leurs missions sur des images de
patrick jacques de dixmude est dessaisi
en hausse de 10% sur les yvelines pour
les défenseurs les délégués défenseur
des droits du défenseur des droits
1614 saisine exactement en 2017 c'est un
chiffre donc en hausse légèrement par
rapport à 2016 il ya onze délégués
présents sur le département des yvelines
est notamment deux présents à trappes et
dui en cours il ya monsieur tavener qui
lui déléguer à trappes et puis il ya
monsieur aunès à guyancourt on va
commencer avec vous vous êtes en place
vous êtes délégué depuis seulement
quelques mois quelques semaines à
trappes vous avez été saisie de 60
dossiers ce que vous pouvez nous
rappeler sur quel quels sont vos sur
quelle chance vous intervenez
précisément sur ces dossiers pour où on
peut vous saisir par exemple et
socialement sur le droit social
un des problèmes de rsa trop perçus sur
rs a également des problèmes fiscaux des
problèmes d'impôts de taxes d'habitation
beaucoup à trappes beaucoup de gens ont
des difficultés pour payer leur taxe
d'habitation également j'ai quelques
dossiers sur le droit des enfants
est ce que c'est la même chose est ce
que c'est la même tendance à guyancourt
est ce qu'on vous saisit sur sur les
mêmes sur le même dossier
généralement c'est des problèmes on dit
de service service public est ce qu'on
entend par là écoutez non le pur
lui en course est un petit peu plus
varié bien sûr je suis en poste depuis
comment plus longtemps ça fait à peu
près une année et il y a des problèmes à
la fois sociaux c'est vrai mais il y a
des problèmes également lié à la
nationalité liées aux permis de conduire
liés aux cartes grises des problèmes
avec des gens d'origine
divers et variés il faut pas penser que
le milieu ce n'est qu'un milieu
défavorisé j'ai des problèmes également
fiscaux c ur des comment des questions
majeures pour les gens des professions
libérales architectes médecins etc
donc c'est très varié mais comme vous le
disiez tout à l'heure il s'agit vraiment
de dysfonctionnement de service public
parce que vous savez que le délégué
défenseur des droits intervient sur des
champs très variés la déontologie
policière les droits de l'enfant la
discrimination etc
c'est vrai que là il s'agit de
dysfonctionnement de service public
alors souvent des questions liées à la
caf à la caisse primaire d'assurance
maladie
les dossiers retraites j'en passe il y
en a d'autres
ce qui veut dire que les gens qui
viennent vous voir sont parfois un peu
désarmée face à la complexité de
l'administration fiscale vous vous êtes
là pour les aider pour apporter votre
expertise soutiens tout à fait la
première chose que l'on fait dans ces
cas là par exemple en matière fiscale
on commence par expliquer le vocabulaire
fiscale les gens beaucoup allaient enfin
les administrés ont beaucoup de mal à
coller à comprendre ça cette année on en
une action un peu particulière vous
savez que la déclaration de revenus va
être désormais dématérialisée bien sûr
pu trappe on a eu on a essayé de
d'informer les gens sur ce sujet un pur
même si c'est pas obligatoire pour tout
le monde on a cette année on a commencé
à informer les gens j'ai commencé à
informer les gens sur ce sujet les gens
qui viennent me voir en moyenne un
chèque en moyenne chaque délégué du
défenseur du droit sur les yvelines est
en charge de 115 à 140 747 dossiers on
le disait principalement des dossiers
pour réclamations sur service public
mais il ya aussi discrimination et
droits de l'enfant c'est peut-être des
sujets sur lesquels on on sait moins
qu'on peut qu'on peut vous saisir alors
effectivement moi je
j'ai eu deux saisines je l'expliquais
tout à l'heure à la réunion de
discrimination faite par internet parce
que on peut saisir également le délégué
défenseur des droits par la procédure
internet et non pas par un rendez-vous
direct à la permanence moi je tiens une
permanence sur le jeudi toute la journée
à la maison de justice de guyancourt
alors il y à des sources variées de
saisine à la maison de justice de
guyancourt il y à des juristes qui
reçoit des citoyens enfin des personnes
du secteur
et lorsqu'il voit qu'il ya une
possibilité auprès du délégué défenseur
de droits à ce moment là il nous les
emplois voilà comment ça se passe alors
en ce qui concerne les droits de
l'enfant je n'ai pas eu à traiter
vraiment de droits de l'enfant et j'ai
expliqué également tout à l'heure lors
de la réunion la conférence de presse
que j'ai eu un exemple d'un enfant
handicapé qui n'est peut-être pas pris
dans une mairie j'ai traité la faire à
peu près jusqu'au bout j'ai eu réponse
est également nous avons eu réponse
également de la conseillère l'adjointe
au maire d'une commune limitrophe de
paris mais pas du côté de guyancourt et
pour moi cette donné satisfaction
après l'enfant n'a pas été primé pour
d'autres raisons
en tout cas on est allé au bout de la
démarche c'est là l'essentiel pour le
délégué défenseurs du droit alors les
délégués défenseur du défenseur des
droits existent depuis depuis 2011
est ce que vous diriez que votre rôle
aujourd'hui est encore plus essentiel
face à on le disait face à une ministre
à sion qui seront va dire qui se
compliquent peut-être qui se complexifie
parfois aussi où il ya moins de liens
qu'auparavant tout passe par internet
est ce que vous diriez que votre rôle
est encore plus peut-être important
qu'avant quand quand il y avait des
contacts plus facile avec les
différentes institutions mais tout à
fait notre les deux délégués vous l'a
dit tout à l'heure la fracture sociale
et surtout la fracture internet crée une
distance entre l'administration et les
administrés et de plus en plus
d'administrer et notre hall
effectivement nous c'est d'essayer de
réduire cette distance
et donc du coup si vous avez besoin
éventuellement de contacter un délégué
du défenseur des droits vous pouvez vous
rendre sur internet sur le site internet
défenseur des droits point fr un détour
par les strass les paillettes et le
soleil pour refermer ce journal toute
cette semaine nous vous présentons les
yvelinois présent pour le 71e festival
de cannes
focus aujourd'hui sur les étudiants qui
se rendent à la grande fête du cinéma
avec forcément des rêves plein la tête
la troisième le troisième numéro de
cannes 78,7 avec grégory et canal et les
images sont signés alexis à garneau
chaque année 80 mille festivaliers
débarque à cannes pour la grande fête du
cinéma à côté des professionnels du
milieu ce sont ceux aussi en devenir des
étudiants à qui viennent pour la plupart
à leur premier festival et victoria
roblin et nicolas rodriguez sont de 3
yes l'institut de l'image et du son à
del en cours ils ont inscrit leur court
métrage le temps d'un regard dans un
espace dédié le chante film corner
[Musique]
victoria nicolas avant de parler du
court métrage le temps d'un regard
pendant votre présence ici à cannes pour
des étudiants en cinéma qui viennent de
terminer leur cursus qu'est le qu'est ce
que ça représente d'être ici à laon pour
nous c'est très important d'être ici
parce que c'est parce qu'on désire
rencontrer beaucoup de on désire
rencontrer du monde
notamment pour faire parler un peu de
notre de notre court métrage et se faire
des nouvelles relations pour des projets
à venir se cultiver aussi un peu parce
qu'il ya une énorme diversité de films
de jean donc voilà il ya plein de films
hyper intéressant à découvrir qu'on
n'aurait pas forcément l'occasion de
découvrir ou redécouvrir ailleurs et
voilà et participer aux soirées après
pour rencontrer des gens et discuter un
peu tout ça quand on est dans le monde
du cinéma c'est le lieu où il faut être
surtout pour nous disons que comme on
n'a pas de connaissances dans le cinéma
mine de rien cannes pendant quinze jours
c'est quand même une réunion de
professionnels ou même avec des rendez
vous pendant un an à paris on
on n'arriverait pas rencontré autant de
gens donc on va dans des soirées on
rencontre des professionnels
si on est au bon endroit au bon moment
qu'on a le bon scénario on peut avoir
une opportunité qu'ailleurs on n'aurait
pas alors vous avez inscrit six au short
film corner le court métrage le temps
d'un regard ça parle de quoi
autant ailleurs alors le temps d'un
regard c'est une passion amoureuse
lien en fait croiser son ex et le temps
d'un regard elle vit un souvenir où elle
ce soin de leurs moments forts de leurs
relations
donc nous en fait on a souhaité parler
d'une passion amoureuse parce que à part
quelques films où j'ai trouvé ça
vraiment crédible comme un vieux film je
sais pas si vous connaissez césar et
rosalie voilà ou même l'offre de gaspar
noé je trouve que leur passion amoureux
sont crédibles à l'écran et c'est ça que
je trouve qu'il manque un petit peu donc
on a essayé de faire la même chose avec
un genre un peu plus particulier voilà
dernière question le temps d'un regard
est inscrit ici c'est un court métrage
qui a déjà été récompensé et qui est
sélectionné dans d'autres festivals
c'est ça alors depuis quelques mois on
l'inscrit à plusieurs festivals en
france et dans le monde entier
finalement il a été récompensé
le prix de la photographie au cinéma
tort donc un festival français et il a
été sélectionné au toronto film festival
est un film c'est au los angeles film
festival aussi merci victoria nicolas
merci à vous
[Musique]
comme chaque jour zoom sur un film
financé par la région ile-de-france le
silencio ce de béatrice seigner est
sélectionné à cannes au sein de la
quinzaine des réalisateurs
il met en lumière une famille qui a fui
le conflit armé en colombie dans lequel
a disparu le père elle trouve refuge sur
une petite île au milieu de l'amazonie
mais découvre très vite que lille est
habitée par des fantômes
nous avons le bagne à lui
twilight n'est pas capitaine spock
c'est la fin de cannes 78 retour dès
demain pour faire connaissance avec
d'autres yvelinois du festival
et c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le journal
tout de suite retrouvé mes l'anip ok
pour le 7-8 culture belle soirée à tous
sur tv 78
[Musique]